- trop proche ou considérer celui-ci est bien d'
accord semaine après
oh c'est bleu une eau ici
pour vous les gens
oui j'ai fini d'accord pour moi aussi j'ai pensé
hé arrêtez d'enregistrer d'
accord mais très bas bas et à travers l'
écart au milieu ouais  d'accord ouais je sais
que tu veux avoir ça ouais on
reste encore si j'aime entendre ça non
par ici ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
tu as appris dans la zone médiane
ouais ouais bas hé ouais de haut
en bas c'est votre joueur bouddhiste
horrible donc il n'a eu aucun problème
avec votre auto avec le droit
je m'ai demandé de gagner le livre de ce gars est l'
auteur du droit ici les garçons ouais peut
-être faire un autre coup de gars juste à la fin
ici faites demi-tour et revenez sur l'
audience opposée c'est très bien je
veux que vous filmiez quelque chose que vous connaissez de l'
iceberg vous avez ce très brillant ouais
magnifique je veux que vous essayiez d'obtenir
ce bien d'accord j'obtiendrai ce que nous venons de
faire  une autre course basse d'abord le o
direction pposite et ensuite nous aurons des
gros plans ouais vous avez la largeur de la
gauche qui va juste des turbidités qui
étaient un tremblement ici regardez ce problème
pour le chef de la caméra peut-je problème
ouais ouais vous savez ce que le haut de  le je
dis que je suis belle ouais hé ouais d'
accord si nous nous retournons et allons
un autre genou en arrière dans la même
direction que nous avons fait il y a un instant mais ensuite
quand nous arrivons au deuxième arrêt iceberg
et je ferai des gros plans  des autres
enclos de la glace sur terre
oh cool ils ont laissé ces bas passer par le
même le même la même gamme ouais j'espère que
tu viens un peu trop loin c'est juste
un autre cercle pour l'orbiter et
je montais ouais maintenant nous arrivons  dans
leur satellite hé oh ouais descends
allonge-toi ici pour le sommet J'aime l'
idée orthodoxe magnifique nous nous arrêtons
viens couru dans le vent sur le deuxième
et j'en ferai des gros plans d'accord
nous gardons cette histoire d'altitude  histoire mais
ouais nous devons ralentir derrière toi souvent
mais nous devenons  turbulent d'accord d'accord
viens juste dans le vent ici ouais
on va faire ça lentement je n'étais pas un
peu plus loin de l'iceberg d'
accord de la très peu de couleur les
corrals donc du bruit d'accord qui a un
regard brillant sur l'eau qui coule  à la fonte,
la glace fond dessus glace glace sympa
vous pouvez voir la vidéo sur l'eau à propos de deux -
eh - d'accord concentrez-vous
ouais d'accord les deux femmes sont un peu plus
grandes
il y aura de l'eau ce que vous devriez
faire maintenant et je suis juste  Je regarde
juste en regardant mais l'eau est belle ici
et je peux me secouer donc le plus souvent ça
ressemble à un tatou et nous venons
de déménager vers la droite pour que Yong puisse prendre
une douche ouais la même chose parce que les
autres savent que c'est bon  pour toi Oh avec le
vent vient d'où à partir de là pour
plus est alors tu peux prendre un plus gros
nez pour aller rouler ouais si tu peux dire que la glace
est belle j'ai l'air bien je rejette
continue d'accord va à celui-ci le prochain
utilisé  sur votre fatwa n'allez pas sur le chemin des artisans d'
accord pour que nous fassions quelques achats
Je suis une courte pause plus proche et nous en avons besoin tout le temps hey bruh cornée si je ne me soucie pas de moi pour l'épinglage à vos jambes afin d'épingler sur le dessus Dieu ouais nous nous déplaçons juste dessus dans une minute d'accord je suis  fini
hé arrête ça on est comme une piscine
ah je pourrais même regarder les gens il y a un
spa exactement d'
accord
Toby tu vas d'accord ouais continue juste
là ça va glisser
je ne peux pas tous finir là merci d'
accord alors  allez directement à cette
restriction pour la caméra ou il y a un
espace de vie
J'ai pensé à leur vitesse combien cela
peut prendre pensez que vous ne le faites pas dix notes
sont-ils ont un poteau de spa à l'extérieur ne fait pas
mal la grande nuit vos enfants
nagent trou
d'accord, y a-
t-il un règlement là-bas
village de balle Le
travail d'Osby va être très
spectaculaire du spectacle que
vous aimez l'iceberg J'ai vu votre garçon quand
l'autre expérience venant en Indiana
vous travailliez un enfer dessus J'ai pris une
elle est tombée sur l'iceberg  c'est sûr
que vous avez été à notre sujet ou à l'autre
Capric  orn je suis basé ici viser le miroir
et le chauffeur Lee Morgan qui a parlé
du diable
oui venant pour le Western nous avons besoin de
risquer aimé créer ce soir nous
tombons ici
donc après qu'une star d'information ait
chamboulé
un couple là-bas là-bas vous pouvez
voir  deux gros bouquets près de l'autre côté
de celui-ci le vôtre gros d'
accord Peter je vais tourner à droite
Toby va
oui monsieur ce grand est beau mon dieu
j'adore il
y a un très gros indice il y a eu d'
accord allons-y tu as le dessus de  le
top mon plan c'est mieux comme une piscine au
milieu qui est son père Peter celui
qui est une eau au milieu d'accord ça
a un morceau de bois au milieu un
moment
cette soupe offrant une amitié saoudienne à
ouais le vent d'hiver est  se déplacer sur la
colline
oh ok oh attends ok j'ai fini
ouais j'ai le gros pour toi Pete je me suis
faufilé là-bas c'est juste un carré
oh je plaisante on a le tien qui
travaille là-bas et quelques termes là je
pense que ça  est le plus grand ou ouais ou
comme w  euh mais c'est chacun pour avoir un
trou dedans ou quelque chose non s'il vous plait
on accélère ouais
belle Europe la faute à la grippe
mais Google
oh ouais tu veux toi un autre cercle mais
plus bas plus bas
Oh un peu d'altitude et un peu plus
loin  loin de là d'accord dans l'autre sens
pour que je puisse voir que les nuages derrière lui sur une lon
ue guerre le flaque dans mec nous descendons
'accord allez maintenant d'accord juste
un peu plus loin de ça
juste aller tout droit un peu et donc
je  obtenir qu'un nuage volumineux sur
leur chemin
un gars qui cuisine pour oncle un peu
plus de vitesse
s'arrête maintenant ici à Flyway voulez-vous en
finir jeune mais je vais
probablement vous lancer un ok ce merveilleux
je ne peux pas finir  d'accord, nous allons au-dessus
de celui-ci, le premier indice, je euh, je
ne peux pas me le permettre et puis
nous pouvons voler au-dessus de
cette gamme, mais encore mieux d'
accord d'accord j'ai terminé merci pour celui-
là  aussi
bien survolez le prochain espace d'
accord mais d'accord d'accord bienvenue dans le
printemps chaud  gs la prochaine fois ouais mais attendez je
réfléchis quand vous irez à la faculté nous pourrons les
voir là-bas donc mais nous pouvons prendre les
premières photos de toute façon bien d'être de retour
bon tentez votre chance maintenant le temps a une
chanson ok vous tous pour vous Peter non  ok
c'est sympa
pour toi ouais là on passe au prochain pot
mais le meilleur c'est celui qu'on a vu
au début l'eau qu'on a près du
bateau était noire bonjour
c'est nos yeux du haut je vois
ça prend là-bas tu vois le  hôte oh
non ce que les crochets derrière la source chaude
deuxième ces gens travaillent sur le pétrole sont
à notre heure de vie il y a la Maison
Blanche là-bas d'accord d'accord celui-ci
premier les
garçons de retour en premier nous avons l'air incroyable oh
c'est bien au fait la vie  c'est beau de
trier ce droit comme une chienne droite de l'île
elle est incroyable
et mais ce n'est pas le photographe qui
travaille dans un seul puits car c'est
bien cette bière peut-on faire un peu le tour
un peu mais ce n'est pas trop près d'
accord d'accord d'accord merci  vous beaucoup
là parce que je sorte de tirer fr  om les
trucs tous ces gentils
et on fait le tour des élévateurs ces
distances c'est en noir et blanc
merci magnifique Oh fantastique
j'ai un toi comme un Jojo hein ouais l'
attente est finie l'histoire du pas pour le
pilote le vent pousse Western un gagnant
Oh to  fermez notre ascension attendez un peu d'
accord maintenant nous tournons d'accord d'accord
parfait jusqu'à seulement la chatte d'accord c'est bien
avant
comme ça Tommy d'accord tu me manques ouais d'accord
je vais sauter ça ouais nous pouvons plonger les
vérifier plus fort à droite
là nous pouvons  baignade